prima di iniziare ecco il tutorial su
come abbiamo realizzato questo pop hit
gigante abbiamo preso dei cartoni
abbiamo poi disegnato dei cerchi
utilizzando una ciotola per creare i
cerchi uguali e ovviamente c'era il
nostro assistente berlino il cagnolino
che controllava tutti i lavori e
approvava tutto eccolo qua
questo passaggio deve essere fatto da un
adulto bisogna tagliare i cerchi con un
taglierino per avere poi questi tutti in
cui metteremo i nostri pop hit è da
verificare pretendenti perché qua ad
esempio berlino ha rubate tutti i cerchi
non voleva più ri darceli pantano contro
un frisbee
ed ecco qua berlino che continua a
controllare se abbiamo realizzato bene
il profitto gigante e pensava fosse un
giochino per lui infatti guardate come
si diverte
berlino pensava proprio che avessimo
costruito un giochino per lui si stava
divertendo tantissimo
[Musica]
scegliete voi quanti cartoni volete
utilizzare in base a quanto volete che
sia grande il vostro hobbit poi potete
colorarlo con i colori che volete per
creare ipocrite infilate dei palloncini
gonfi e se volete metterci qualcosa di
strano in alcuni palloncini consisterà
ancora più divertente il truccarli poi
metteteli uno sopra l'altro tech
necessario mettere dello scotch per
tenerli fermi e voilà ecco qua
ecco sbaglia troppo fit si è più fatto
vedere il tutorial ed eccolo qua pronto
esteso come signora colista challenge
dove ho pensato cosa potrebbe fare
diventare questa challenge ancora più
divertente ogni palloncino potrebbe
esserci o semplicemente l'aria oppure
potrebbe esserci una penitenza e
colorante
perché abbiamo questa maglia è servito
perché volevo dirvi bianchi perché chi
si sporca di più avrà aperto
chi invece avrà la maglietta più bianca
avrà vinto nel challenge fra poco
infatti ci trasferiremo fuori il
giardino per non fare un caos star
dentro casa e scegliere il colore
gireremo la rosa e poi tireremo il dado
per scegliere il numero del pop hit ad
esempio se capita blu 3 dovremmo fare
123 e tu scoppiare quell 8 potete vedere
in alcuni balletti di stevenage a dove
c'è un davanti ad esempio qui
[Musica]
appetiti anche voi che cosa sembra
una creatura un po malvagia coi capelli
alti altri una strega guarda sembra una
signora di profilo
e tv una strega sala tipo la maledizione
del pop hit chi capiterà
frenino
super divertente quindi mettetevi comodi
prendete i pop corn e ci siamo subito e
lasciate un mi piace perché non venga
poi a berlino vuoi partecipare titola
challenge dava il meglio di no perchè se
no ti mangeresti palloncini ed eccoci
qua in giardino ma prima di iniziare
abbiamo una challenge anche per voi ora
tirerò questo dato è il numero che
capiterà saranno i secondi entro cui
dovrete cliccare mi piace fronti
vieni
6 avete sei secondi per lasciarmi piazze
5 4 3 2
1 o tempo sono subito riusciti e ora
iniziamo la nostra tale adesso lanciamo
il dado e a chi esce il numero più alto
inizia per primo la challenge
396 piaciuto 3 marginale tocca a me
uno anch'io ho bisogno di farlo ok il
ritiro
segundin il trono ora devo girare la
ruota per vedere quale colore mi capita
venite bari ecco con la ruota dei colori
ve la ricordate pronti
rosso rosso ma non abbiamo il rosso ma
il colore più vicino e l'arancione
quindi il arancione per il mondo mi
capita di cambiare ora tiro il dato per
vedere qual è il numero di palloncino
dopo scoppiare
schivata la strega per poco ok devo
scoppiare questo palloncino speriamo che
non ci sia niente dentro ma soprattutto
io odio scoppiare i palloncini mi fanno
paura non sta a guardare e quindi
vediamo locazioni de rita
non c'era niente dai propri maglietta
bianca ancora pulitissima tanto che ho
camerale ha detto zio
celeste
ora diventato
6 bari c day
1 2 3 4
5 e 6 no e questo e mi sa che c'è del
colorante
ma perché sono sempre sfortunato italia
io mi aiutava sono sempre sfortunato
quei giorni dai vado ad
halo c'era pochissimo colorante che
fortuna il futuro però un volo poco che
una maglietta si emani anna era il
colorante blu comunque si vede i
dibattiti sporcate anche qualche classe
tocca a me è per ora io sono in
vantaggio anche questa spettacolare ma
le
tv ass
il mio colore preferito speriamo che mi
porti fortuna in realtà noi abbiamo sia
il rota che il viola ma non c'è il rote
il viola quindi quando capita questo che
sia rosa che viola possiamo scegliere
noi se il rosso o il viola ammessi con
me piace tantissimo e rosa giallorossa
buona idea
numero 5
1 2 3 4 5
vecchie non mi è capitato niente a
pronti
[Musica]
è un vitolo macchiata in quella
maglietta bianca capitale adult vanzina
vai ti renda
ok quindi 1
2 3 4 5 6 posto salvo forse tele
scampata vediamo cosa succede io mi
allontano
che stasera non vi attenete mitrato
qualcosa dell'occhio tocca a me
[Musica]
allora nei blu ne rimangono solo due
questo fin qui sicuramente c'è il
colorante perché si vede e questo forse
vuoto vediamo 6 1 2 3 4 5
che fortuna
non vi stanno macchiato di
lavoro piano però
non c'è quindi devi andare con onore più
vicino
speriamo che capiti la strega ma speravo
che mi capiti
11 facevano sì che non
ne sono quasi sicuro che farà c'è niente
quindi lo faccio proprio la volta a bada
la faccio proprio con me davanti non ho
paura
che fuori
perché a me
prima da solo questo ma non c'è neanche
bisogno di scegliere un numero no non
devono anche tirare il dato perché se
stato corretto e meglio che ti allontani
ma che
si è macchiato tutta la moglie janet ha
quindi un rosso di smontaggio to
perdition
colorante che avrà la maglietta più
bella dopo inter ora io colorante un po
bloom po rozza
quindi
rosso
quella strega
o no ma ci hanno tutte due coronate
trarre
123 no
123 penna la strega
che ti porterà
a vedere da vicino una la strega fine ai
piedi o piano
ok va dove vai
o no ai nomadi sporca del maialetto la
maledizione della strega c'erano anche
dei glitter
vitale sto perdendo per il lancio
della maglietta sporca
tocca a me
[Musica]
roth ma arancione si cela ancora uno
o no e rimosso questo arancione era il
colorante dentro lo vedete e quindi
anche questa volta non c'è bisogno di
che ci ha ridato
indietro
sbaglio
guarda circolato anche qui ognuno è
anche sul rosa
ora sono in svantaggio
allora siccome alcuni colori abbiamo
finiti e alcuni non ci sono se capita un
colore che non c'è il bisognerà prendere
il colore abbiamo già trovato
verde non ce lo abbiamo però c'è blu o
rosso e la terza migliore
giallo è ancora capitato
212 vista che non c'è niente lì che
fortunato io scappo vado
ma che succede è scappato in fondo
signora fatto che non è scoppiato e
soffiando
non c'era niente
opportuna scritto cambio
giallo numero 2 m 2
2 ma che non c'è niente dentro così
fortunata anche questa volta
capitale poi
blu che abbiamo finito quindi il colore
a fianco giallo o no il numero
5 vai cota
capire se ha il colorante o no quello
che fortuna la
roccia solo abbiamo lui abbiamo finito
il berbero siamo
blu l'abbiamo finito quindi rosa un po
scelgo i viola e ancora non ne abbiamo
scoppiato nessuno dei viola numero 4
poco comune a
che corse il colorante io mi nascondo
palme e qua in basso mi devo fare un po
[Applauso]
anche per
questo credo che un po liquido perché
scomodi dottor calmare una brutta di
tutti
marrone guardate che mi
sto perdendo allora siccome è rimasto
solo viola e rosa suggeriamo noi
giuristi colori quale se gli ora siccome
sono 33
adesso lo scoppio giusti che colore
scegli io scelgo il viola ok ti renda
dove viola rosa e oro giallo che
numerosa trono quindi 12 34
42 34
navi testo per fortunata questi giochi
guardate la mia maglia
l'elenco il rosa speriamo che numero
21 giu due mi sai che vede il colorato
io mi allontano
e
penso che sia un rosso o lo sguardo
calcolato e che qui era rosa
rosa almeno è bellissimo il colore ma
non mia moglie the crow firma occhiata
sto perdendo e colore se egli mi sa mi
sa che scelgo il giallo anche se no di
verde che è accollato sopra quindi
rotatoria che tirava il dato
troppo
ops se nel colorate o non c'era
purtroppo c'era e con la dante era il
colore atteggia come se l'eroe poco è
arrivato anche poi faccia e la fortuna a
dubitare sul pre fortuna se però le
parle è già arrivato in faccia ma non ne
sono la maglietta ora io scelgo il viola
numero
4 1 2 3 4
minuti se del colorante
quali
un
colorante nero focato portano così
sfigata e questa sale di quasi tutti i
two tone capitale i colori se gli io
scelgo in rosa anche il risultato dei
[Musica]
45 e sena dei con questo visto che c'è
colorate finalmente vitaly borker ah ah
ah ah vediamo perché vado aiutami ad
andare
ti sei sbracato
di alcuni trans è sbarcato finalmente
colorante blu
in fondo ora ne rimangono solo due
possiamo giocare a carte
con la forza per facilitare cosa sei io
scelgo c'è un occhio rosa vediamo carta
famiglia fatto
io
penserò o non vincerò
se non c'era colorante biba speriamo che
nell'ultimo piano si sia il colorante
per vitale
[Musica]
ma che cosa fa soldato vede giuliante
niente
ultimo pop hit bari
vediamo
non c'è niente quindi abbiamo scambiato
su tutti a mauro gir
guardate come diventato il pop hit
gigante
è pieno di colori anche dentro da
sciacca
divertente e ora vediamo chi ha vinto e
chi ha perso in base alle magliette
questa è la mia maglietta però devo dire
che sembra un quadro
almeno poi avrò una nuova maglietta da
indossare tutto colorate può anche fare
quel gioco in cui cerchiamo di vedere
verdure che figura c'è in queste forme
la mia maglietta e quattro le mie varie
e vediamo vitale questa è la mia vita è
questa le mie mani e le mie braccia
ma lo sai che non lo so che ha vinto dai
due unità che vinto tu parole molto
carino questa maglia ma braga tipo
quello della agusta possono al proprio
stiloso
scrivete nei commenti che ha vinto in
base a chi ha la maglietta più sporca ha
perso chi ha la maglietta meno sporca
oudin però ti alla maglietta più bella e
vitale
perché tranne i commenti non stasi un
bel mi piace fa ti sto pericolo è stato
il momento più divertente secondo voi e
se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila
ducati ci sarà un'altra challenge con il
pop il grunge e orami da quattro case
lines quindi care per vedere inoltre
altri vinca the superato preferite buona
visione